at the odds of getting or giving the
virus to others
is very very low if you're both been
fully vaccinated
and out the open air some big news from
the centers for disease control today
we now have new mask guidelines good
afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us here at four o'clock i'm
christian casadas i'm kirstjen joyce the
cdc now saying
fully vaccinated americans don't need to
wear a mask outdoors in most
cases president biden asked all
americans to wear masks for his first
100 days in office
and now his administration is relaxing
some of those recommendations
starting today if you're fully
vaccinated
and you're outdoors you need and not in
a big crowd
you no longer need to wear a mask fully
vaccinated people can now take off
masks while exercising outdoors
attending small
outdoor gatherings with a mixture of
people who are vaccinated and
unvaccinated
and dining at outdoor restaurants with
friends from multiple households
we know that the virus spreads very well
indoors
until more people are vaccinated and
while we still have more than 50 000
cases a day mask use indoors will
provide
extra protection the new guidance comes
as the administration redoubles efforts
to reach out to those who are reluctant
to get the vaccine
this is another great reason to go get
vaccinated
now now the number of daily doses
administered fell from a high of about
three and a half million two weeks ago
to 2.7 million on monday the federal
government stands ready to help states
put shots into arms as quickly as
possible the cdc says there are seven
states
alabama alaska georgia louisiana
mississippi west virginia and wyoming
now administering less than 70 percent
doses delivered
most states are still above 85 percent
it's important to note at this point
nevada has not yet relaxed its
mask mandate we did reach out to state
leaders for comment on those new
guidelines they tell us they are
reviewing the announcement
and look to address any changes to state
directives in the coming days christian